our biology changes in response to the
environment around us in ways that are
not obvious to us so when you change the
environment around you or inside of you
you can have profound effects on how you
feel how you perform and just the
quality of your life
I've made it my mission to make the
changes in the environment around me
that make me more effective at
everything I do I'm a professional
biohacker I'm the creator of bulletproof
coffee bulletproof has always been about
identifying and taking advantage of
every single thing that makes people
perform better when you drink it you
just don't care about food no cravings
no hunger for four to six hours and you
feel a kind of mental clarity that you
probably haven't felt in years
I used to weigh 300 pounds I was having
some serious cognitive problems my
mid-20s even though my career was taking
off I had bad health to be perfectly
honest even though I was exercising even
though I ate a low-fat diet I was
frustrated and I made it my mission to
hack this problem to literally go out
and change it so I decided to put my
full resources and efforts into
upgrading myself part of this was a trip
to Tibet I went to a very remote region
called Mount Kailash and it's 17,000
feet elevation when it's 10 degrees
below zero you can expect to feel like a
zombie that's a bad woman handed me a
pot mug of yak butter tea sounds gross
and isn't that flavorful but I drink it
and I felt the lights turned back on I
was amazed at how good I felt when I
came back to the states i said i want to
recreate that feeling i did all the
different types of tea and realized
coffee worked way better than tea for
creating the state of clarity that I was
seeking one of the most important
variables was the coffee beans
themselves different types of coffee
have a different effect on how you feel
and when I isolated mold toxins as the
primary differentiator and coffee I
developed lab testing so that I could
always have the right coffee that didn't
cause a crash or jitters or that kind of
cranky coffee feeling it's then blended
with grass-fed butter instead of milk
this is because milk has things that
stick to the antioxidants and coffee and
butter doesn't have very much of that in
it now for the secret ingredient brain
octane oil brain octane oil is about six
percent of the fat in coconut oil the
performance benefits are so noticeable
the lack of sugar cravings it just turns
on right away we add the hot coffee
what it tastes like is the best latte
you've ever had and you drink it and
then 52 minutes later I feel more like
myself and then two hours later I didn't
even want to eat the bagel that was in
the conference room like the doughnuts
lost their sirens song for me because
those really strong cravings for food
they just go away and that's the amazing
thing for vulgar of coffee and that's
the secret of why it's so popular
because it works
things that make us better humans are
what I'm interested in my mission with
bulletproof is to show people what it
feels like to be stronger and to have
the energy and to be able to bring it
every day coffee's just the beginning
you